si belle attaque avec nous pour le
débris
[Applaudissements]
voilà moi la chine je te fais un petit
peu de passes comme rien si ça va ça va
oui alors je sais pas si c'est l'effet
du passage de laurent ruquier avant-hier
mais hier il ya eu une série de jeux de
mots incroyables ici un peu plus notion
de connais très bien
on joue avec les chroniqueurs à qui veut
gagner des millions du gel douche les
assurances ou une marque de lave linge
nommé plus belles laverie laetitia
collaborait avec un autre artiste dans
un autre domaine
lequel à la sortie une bd nommé tintin
et milou
ouais on aurait quand même magnifique on
est prêt un pour réaliser le rêve
d'isabelle ici présentes faire venir les
grosses têtes sur ces huit séries dr tu
as aussi présenté le nouveau mister
france et je salue yann qu'on peut
applaudir s'il vous plaît qui était
ralentie
allez y avait de la bonne viande sur le
plateau mesdames accrochez vous stevie
aussi
[Musique]
on le surnomme le beau gosse du soixante
dix huit cent vingt ayant il est beau
ils sont de plus en plus beaux les
mister france et puis si lille hier tu
as encore reçu des gens en colère contre
les fermetures pour cause sanitaires
avaient donc l'heure de retrouver notre
documentaire historique
babac alips l'épisode du jour s'appelle
à corona war on adore 17 mars 2020 le
jour j comme je peux plus sortir
la france est à l'arrêt les commerces
ont fermé les rues sont vides
la survie de l'humanité ne tient qu'à un
fil le fil d'actu des réseaux sociaux
jo mais un homme le général baba premier
va se battre et résister contre l'agonie
c'est ce que nous allons vous raconter
dans ce nouveau numéro de ba baca lips
dans son quartier général de boulogne le
général baba organisent la résistance et
crée la dark armés parmi eux les aînés
le maréchal verdez héros de la bataille
d'evian pas la ville la bouteille d'eau
et le colonel morinie à ne pas confondre
avec marignan marignan 115 115 alors que
maureen y est né enquin 112 pendant des
mois comme sous l'ancien régime le
général baba reçoit les gens du peuple
pour écouter leurs doléances et des
formats qui manifestent à toulouse à
l'heure actuelle la non commerce ne
peuvent pas rouvrir on est en train de
crever clairement nous sommes en train
de crever 14 mois vous travaillez pas
quatorze mois sans salaire les combats
sont d'une rare violence et parfois en
pleine bataille
le général baba qui reste un être humain
sensible craque ça vient vers toi tu es
dans montre en retrait pas déjà de base
en plus maintenant que je montre les
cris du peuple n'étant pas suffisant le
général baba décide de sortir
l'artillerie lourde
la 2e division blindée la division
blindée est une habituée du front normal
vu la taille du sien du coup il attaque
de toute part notamment face au
bataillon italien du général castaldi et
vous qu'il était prêt à tenter
d'assainir la 2e db tire de partout même
parfois contre la dark armés vous n'avez
ce soir est dorénavant que pur mépris
face à lara sera ambiante le général
baba mobilise toutes les forces de la
chaîne de commandement
tous les lundis l'armée est mobilisée
john rambo débarque sur ces 8 dès lundi
à 21h05
et tous les mardis la police police
academy numéro deux aux boules en ses
moyens
suffiront ils pour sortir de la crise
d'où le saurez dans le prochain épisode
de ba baca lips et l'examen buccal et
moi j'aime bien je sais pas ce que vous
en pensez vous on a public peut voter
mais attendez on en est très content
brabant yacine
[Applaudissements]